un retrait définitif des troupes
américaines d'afghanistan qui a commenté
moscou ce matin le chef de la diplomatie
russe s'est exprimé au sujet de l'avenir
du pays où les talibans viennent
d'annoncer la composition de leur
gouvernement la correspondance en russie
d'anthony clairoix
avec la retenue qui le caractérise
sergueï lavrov a réagi aux propos de joe
biden tenue hier dans la soirée en
particulier lorsqu'il a été dit que le
retrait d'afghanistan marquer la fin de
l'interventionnisme américain des propos
qui rappellent au passage ceux tenus par
emmanuel macron il ya tout juste
quelques jours lorsqu'il disait qu'on ne
pouvait imposer la démocratie dans un
pays ministre russe des affaires
étrangères espère maintenant que ses
déclarations ne resteront pas des
paroles en l'air mais seront bien
suivies d'effet au point que
ces chasses aux oeufs désormais les
tentatives d'imposer la démocratie
devraient cesser du moins le président
biden et le président macro l'on dit
presque à l'unisson voyons comment ces
promesses vont être mises en pratique
encore une fois chaque pays doit régler
ses propres affaires de manière
indépendante
tout le monde a admis que cela avait été
une très grande erreur de vouloir
imposer à l'afghanistan le système qui
fonctionnait en occident c'est un pays
qui est traditionnellement assez
décentralisé et dans lesquels les
relations entre les clans et les
différents groupes ethniques sont d'une
grande importance
[Musique]
le président russe s'est également
exprimé sur le sujet qualifiant de
véritable tragédie les ventes allaient
de présence américaine sur place droite
cette ligue américaine ce qui risque
pendant 20 ans les troupes américaines
ont été présentes sur ce territoire et
pendant 20 ans elles ont essayé on peut
même dire sans offenser personne de
civiliser les gens qui vivaient c'est
les ou et lui dit quand on ajoute
qu en fait sont essayé d'établir leurs
propres normes et standards de vie au
sens le plus large du terme joue compris
d'organisation politique de la société
et politique résultat au pieu des
tragédies que des pertes
et cela à temps pour ce qu'il faisait
pour les états unis que et encore plus
pour ceux qui vivent sur le territoire
de l'afghanistan le résultat est nul
pour ne pas dire que tout est devenu
négatif levier qu'autoriseront août mais
qu'il est au livre guinness tonnes
les hold up new way is liscoët ministre
chinois moscou s'est par le passé
toujours prononcé contre les
interventions occidentales de ce type
les responsables russes citent
d'ailleurs souvent comme exemple à ne
pas reproduire le cas de l'intervention
de l'otan en libye en 2011 qui avait
plongé alors le pays dans un véritable
chaos